natalie franklin the genius behind the
instagram account
at nori's black book um of course the
the account that has taken the world by
storm you were just featured on keeping
up with the kardashians
nice to meet you the legend
right in front of us i used to love
reading the blog siri's burn book
it was a really popular account on
tumblr from sarah cruz's perspective and
she would talk about celebrity kids
and i loved it and i was like i would
love you that one day because that's
like my you know style of humor i love
that kind of stuff
and then north was born and you know
they had the babies rs line the
kardashians
and i remember on the phone talking to a
friend of mine saying
can you imagine how upset north probably
is because she's probably like
i should be in chanel balenciaga supreme
like something else
but i'm in this cheap babies rs clothes
and so like a light bulb went off and i
was like oh that's it this is like
the thing so nori because at the time
they require nori but at the time also
kanye kim and north were wearing a
ridiculous amount of black
so i was like okay this kid's always in
black black books so it really was
while the series burn book was my
inspiration i'm like well what can i do
to make it my own and so i don't look
like a complete copycat so give me give
me the full
natalie approach to making content i
mean what goes through your brain
as you're churning out all of this
comedy right
so it's kanye's personality and kim's
personality
so if you watch keeping up kim's very
judgmental with her family
she's the least interesting to look at
she's not in the shoe she's the least
exciting to look at so
she can be out and then kanye has a big
um it
has a big ego like i am the best i just
see our life becoming more and more and
more like the incredibles until we can
finally fly
and there's a dash of chris in there
with the brand like it's all about the
brand
kim you're doing amazing push this me
out
when you're creating content for nori's
black book
who is the easiest kardashian or jenner
to immediately just like anything with
courtney and scott and their kids it's
easy for me to write for scott because
you know his relationships are
hilarious so it's easy to pick on that a
bit and then courtney on the show
she is constantly in conflict with kim
so that speaks directly to north you
know i don't want to film i'm not doing
this
kim there are people dying in glam i'm
not doing glass
my diamond earring came up in the ocean
and it's gone
there's people that are dying kendall is
the most um
normal person in the family like the
most every day like she's not super
glammed up
she she dates you know celebrities but
she's never had like a high profile
relationship and she's not really
a spotlight girl so when she's not
putting herself out there i don't really
have a lot to pull from and
on top of that kendall doesn't have kids
really doesn't have anyone to bully like
she does the districts or like
dream or anything like that is there one
joke
that you're truly just the most proud of
you know what it might sound
weird but the jokes i write about corey
with corey involved are my best because
i don't think people realize corey is
the same age as him
he's like a week or two younger everyone
was going crazy because scott was dating
someone
you know so much younger and yet he's
dating chris and nobody cares
cheers man good health more wealth and
lots of love so
of course it's a parody account knowing
what i know of you
you're very light-hearted you're all
about comedy and laughs
but of course you know you're talking
about real people on this account
and i could very easily see this could
be a situation where
things might get litigious or some cease
and desist letters
um has that ever been a concern of yours
have you actually ever received any
um letters on behalf of the family
saying you gotta you know tweak this or
take it down or we don't like the
account
if i get a cease and desist and desist
letter from the kardashians i'd frame it
like what an honor like what nar that
would be i wish
i don't think i'm important enough to
get a decent distance like i'm not
making that impact enough but i would
have loved that but no they
the family from what i the few
interactions i have they're actually
really good sports they
have this great ability to laugh at
themselves they don't take themselves
too seriously
so um no i don't think that was an issue
i believe you said on the show that
jonathan chubbin has blocked the account
is that true the only people i'm really
black for was miss jonathan
she blocked me real early in the game
yeah jonathan's blocked it blac chyna's
blocked
it i don't think lars has blocked it yet
but definitely
jonathan blac chyna's they did that like
way early in the game
which i'm fine with like and i don't
think it's about
me more than it is about like maybe the
people that read
nori's black book and they might
antagonize a bit so i'm not bitter about
that like i get it
you might not want to see an account
doing that stuff all the time and people
tagging you so
no hard feelings i understand okay it's
good that you understand i am curious
like have you ever reached
out to them through maybe a different
account like i meant no harm
or does it bother you that you're a
thousand percent does not bother me that
i'm blocked
i don't i don't care like i know my
intentions and
you have your reasons for blocking and
i'm not going to question that at all if
it makes your internet experience
better to block then that's you know
your prerogative
they happen to watch this interview is
there anything that you'd like to say
yeah i would just say no hard feelings
um i have no ill intentions it's just
all having a good time
so um please don't feel like there's any
hatred or anything
coming from me we're just having some
fun that's all was there ever
anything you posted that you maybe felt
uh is this a little too
dicey is this maybe bordering on
could be offensive to somebody else um
there's nothing
dicey i think when the the jordan
tristan thing
happened that was rough because
actually any scandal happens i don't
like commenting i don't like doing posts
on it because again they're real people
um i don't want them to feel worse than
they may or may not already feel my
approach is more like
making nor think about it from a
business aspect because north is a
businesswoman she's running an empire
so it was more so you know the kylie and
jordan collections going on sale
what i want for north is she's above the
drama like she's about the bag
and she can't be part of the drama the
drama is messing up the bag or the brand
then she's got to say something when
lamar had to you know
overdose that was a rough time but it's
more in those things when people are
like
what do you have to say and i'm like
well i'm not going to make a joke about
someone overdose so you know what i mean
but i think the more difficult time
before my reveal you know as i before i
came out of the closet as a black woman
um people didn't understand that not
only was the writer black but north is
black so if i make
jokes about the malikas or dream they're
like this is racist and i'm like
i'm black it's not what was the
experience like getting to be
on a reality show as iconic as as
keeping up with the kardashians
it's so crazy it's like like are you
guys real this is insanity
so i have so many questions for you it
was so surreal because
i never thought i'd be on i mean who
thinks they're gonna be on keeping up
because that shows strictly for family
um so it was really crazy getting miked
i felt like so cool
like oh i'm getting miked look at this
they had lighting
um there's cameras everywhere and one of
the cameramen was like are you nervous i
was like i could throw up right now but
they're really easy to talk to and they
made me feel
super comfortable they're super
complimentary the big moment
that we were all waiting for you got to
facetime with norah
and true to character she couldn't be
bothered can you say hi
nice to meet you good careless
do you care all right
i thought that moment was so sweet and
just delicious
and everything i expected and more the
fact that she
was so into her ice cream didn't even
want to make
eye contact like very little eye contact
there don't care and then i told chloe
uh she hates me
hates me and i love it and it's it's
quite all right
um i wouldn't change a thing i actually
wish you would have hung up on me
nori's black book has been part of pop
culture for eight
years realistically how long do you see
yourself doing this definitely
as long as you know it makes sense i'll
keep doing
north but i obviously wanted to do other
type of writing like i'd love to write
for a tv show and
books movies and like just do a bunch of
stuff so i
you know sky's the limit at this point
and hopefully nori's black book will
help me get there
like if chris rock called and he's like
let's do this i'm like yes mr rock let's
do this
have you considered parodying any other
celebrity i did but they don't work for
a couple reasons one because north is
just so unique
in her personality that it's just the
other kids don't give that much
content but also i've tried to do for
beyonce's kids like i did one for the
ivy
that was okay but again it's hard
because you don't see the ivy a lot
i tried to do one for sir and roomie her
twins
um that immediately got shut down the
next day i just
they're like nope sorry this is not a
thing uh
thank god for the crowd yeah exactly
well i think the only natural way to end
this interview would be
for you to graciously tap into your
inner northwest and tell me what do you
think about doing an interview with e.t
after all this success this was a great
opportunity i love being on et
i hope e is watching and see what they
lost i'm all about the brand and
building the empire and securing the bag
and i hope everyone knows that now and i
am the reason the kardashian empire
is what it is northwest
[Applause]
[Music]